mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalkar
there are three rectangles placed in a
row
the width of the first and second
rectangles together is equal to seven
meters
the width of the second and third
rectangles together is equal to 8 meters
if the first rectangle has an area equal
to 20 square meters and the third
rectangle has an area equal to 25 square
meters what is the area of the second
rectangle
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so how can we solve this problem
for ease of presentation let's focus on
just the numbers and i'll remove the
units
suppose the second rectangle has a width
equal to x
we can then calculate the width of the
first rectangle in terms of x and it
will be equal to 7 minus x
we can also do this for the third
rectangle so its width is equal to eight
minus x
now suppose all three rectangles have a
common height that's equal to y
we can calculate the area of the first
rectangle in terms of x and y
seven minus x multiplied by y will be
equal to the area which is equal to
twenty
we can do a similar calculation for the
third rectangle
its area is equal to 25 and that will be
equal to eight minus x multiplied by y
finally we can calculate the area of the
second rectangle in terms of x and y
its area will be equal to x multiplied
by y
we now have three equations for areas of
these rectangles
we can use these equations to solve for
x and y
we will first distribute y in the first
equation
then we will distribute y in the second
equation
from these two equations let's subtract
the second equation from the first
the x y terms will cancel
leaving that y is equal to five
from here we can go back to the first
equation and substitute in for y
we will then solve for x
we will get that x is equal to eight
minus five which is equal to three
we then substitute in to the area of the
second rectangle which is equal to x
multiplied by y and we get the area of
the second rectangle is equal to 15 and
don't forget the square meters the area
of the second rectangle is equal to 15
square meters and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
[Music]
you